[Musique]
[Rires]
comme son maître chien
donc cher auprès de leurs cornes ça va
ouais datant de
ainsi à travers la fraude aux logiques
tout le monde pourrait monde pourrait
tourner ferment pour fermement le de
flash est heureuse exemple sur ma mère
ma mère qui est une catholique en burcy
toujours heureux toujours bien et
l'enjeu qu'occupe confie la mère j'ai un
exemple formidable je fais chaque fois
que j'ai un problème du maintien comme
enjeu comment je pouvais faire pour
avoir l'air heureux dans telle situation
je pense à ma mère elle compte en gravit
très vite voir comment je me voilà sur
le crif
[Musique]
ouais on n'apprend pas un texte en fait
s'est passé dire un texte c'est pas une
question de mémoire
moi je me souviens d'un texte à partir
du moment où j'ai compris comment
nouvelle jouer en cause naturelle de
notre gamme est racontée une caméra qui
tourne en fait c'est le désert à la tête
et actionnaires et puis il faut tout
reconstruire et et moi pour tout
reconstruire et bien je suis je vous le
mets beaucoup ch travail
la dame me coucher quand je prends le
scénario que ça juste avant le nord
parce que j'ai l'impression que le
pendant la nuit
c'est plus continuer à fonctionner
inconsciemment la seule chose qui fait
que je me souviens des phrases que j'ai
à dire c'est que c'est un texte
parallèle que j'ai avec eux que j'ai
construit moi même que j'ai inventé moi
même par exemple passons à table
qu'est ce que tu as eue aujourd'hui si
j'ai c'est à dire eh ben moi entre deux
phrases je vais cogiter ce que je les
pensais alors je vais alors mettre en å
à table
ah c'est bien on a bien mérité notre
repas je pense on a bien travaillé
d'ailleurs est ce que tout le monde a
travaillé ici lui at il travaillé qu'est
ce que tu as fait aujourd'hui voilà moi
c'est le lui at-il travail c'est tout ça
que je prendrai un accord
sur certains tournage les acteurs se
retrouvent très très très c'est pareil
ne tourne pas des magasins courir à
notre coin moi je crois que ça tient
enfin moi je suis que je suis foutu
comme ça je dirais que pendant toute la
journée de tournage en fait je
l'arrêtent pas de penser à ce que je
vais faire du tronc aussi et reste dans
son coin
fanny aussi rétention convaincu au bon
moment on tourne traque tout le monde et
tout le monde vient se mettre ensemble
quelqu'un j'aime parler j'aime bien un
truc je me sens il dérange en fait ça me
dérangeait je suis pas ce qui me dit moi
j'avais même même qu'angélique de
l'acteur français parking
[Rires]
[Musique]